say that the nuclear family is an
example of white supremacist do any of
those ideas make black children's lives
better that makes it worse so it makes
your family does not make really
anybody's lives the single biggest
indicator that you have success of
ending up in prison of graduating high
school of being literate or having sex
sure that's useful because of the
nuclear family right having your mom and
dad right but uncle takes that place of
the dad you can still have those
benefits right it's more so just only
having one parent to depend on it's not
because the nuclear family if one parent
let's say died right but they had the
entire family come in and help those
children they're probably still as well
off right so why is that not happening
in the black community it is it is I
think it's a beautiful thing that you
are living but it's not statistically
it's not statistically there are more
children in the black community yes
single houses it's not even close and
the family is not stepping in I'm gonna
walk out